hi there uh
i want to talk today about freedom of
expression
and particularly uh as it applies to a
recent controversy we've had here in in
canada
where uh leading magazine published an
article which was originally entitled
too asian
and it talked about the fact that some
um
white if you want non-asian students
didn't want to go to
certain universities where there was a
high concentration of
students of asian origin whether they
are
first generation parents or been in
canada for generations
and the white students are quoted in the
article as saying that they felt the
asian students studied too hard and that
the white students again quoted in the
article preferred to party or not study
quite so hard or didn't want to have to
compete with these hard-working asian
students and some asian students are
quoted as saying that they prefer
to be with
other asian students because the white
students spend so much time drinking at
parties and so forth
it wasn't a very brilliant or deep
article
it did describe a fairly widespread
phenomenon and that is that first of all
students of asian origin particularly
east asian and particularly chinese
because in canada that's the largest
source of or ethnic origin if you want
of people of asian origin
um
that they are
relative to their share of the
population they're over represented in
our universities
and this reflects the fact that they
study harder and of course therefore
they have every right to be in the
universities because the universities
uh at the present time
acceptance or admittance is based on
your marks which is probably the right
thing to do
but there are people who don't like it
who feel that
you know it was more fun when
universities were more about partying
probably though uh not all white kids
react the way the kids in this article
uh seem to feel
uh i am sure there are asian
origin kids who prefer to go to a
university where there's more partying
so there's a certain amount of
exaggeration or or stereotyping but it's
a story i mean
every story i read in a magazine it
doesn't strike me necessarily as being
accurate
or brilliant and this one probably
is not brilliant but it does reflect a
widespread attitude
now what's come up now as a result of
this is there are all kinds of
chinese canadians
who are insisting that this magazine
should be boycotted we have a professor
at the university here in vancouver
henry yu who's
more or less encouraging his students to
boycott
uh
the owner of the magazine which is a
company that's involved in
in the distribution of
mobile telephones
uh we have a senator
who stood up and said you know
because in canada again it's not a
policy that i agree with but the
government subsidizes canadian
publications in order that they might
survive against american competition
mclean's magazine which is the magazine
involved in this
article
gets a million and a half dollars from
the government
so the senator vivian poi is saying that
money should be withdrawn because of
this terrible article
what bothers me in this is this
tremendous group pressure
from various vocal
people in this chinese
canadian largely the chinese community
who are trying to shut down
what is essentially the freedom of
expression of the magazine
uh there's nothing in that article
that is uh
you know anti-anybody
um
you know i henry you for example this
professor at ubc who is of chinese
origin i mean he wrote an article uh in
the local newspaper here in vancouver
where he said that vancouver is becoming
an asian city
and he lamented the fact that a certain
part of vancouver
doesn't get it and is still quote
according to him as white as the driven
snow so like he's bothered by the fact
that some areas of vancouver are still
not
asian enough for him to me it's just a
silly comment but
i'm not suggesting that the vancouver
sun should be boycotted because they
printed an article written by henry yu
you know there are asians who say
chinese who choose to live where there
are lots of chinese there are others who
specifically choose to live where there
aren't a lot of chinese for whatever
reason the first group because they feel
more comfortable with other asians and
the second group because they want to
give they want to give their kids
perhaps a a different experience and not
to to be living only with with their own
kind it is an unfortunate fact that in
our schools and universities we do do
tend to see people kind of grouping
together in cliques based on their
ethnic origin i think that's too bad but
it is a fact
and to report on that
is not grounds for a massive
uh sort of uh
indignation by any particular ethnic
group and i think it's scary
that uh
every time a group feels that they're in
some way offended by an article
uh that they have the right
to boycott it demand that its funding be
taken away
uh boycott uh you know the owners who
are in other businesses in other words
to try and
uh
gang up on and pressure
uh these publications to produce
articles that they like
i mean they have every right to write
uh letters to that magazine to comment
in other publications to do whatever
they want be as indignant and offended
as they want to be no one can prevent
them from doing that but it's the idea
that they're gonna
through their collective muscle
force
these publications to to dance to their
tune that's pretty scary stuff
and they've been able to get some of the
more quote progressive
uh municipalities in canada like in
victoria and vancouver and they tried it
in toronto to get the municipal
government to come out and make a
statement condemning this
uh
magazine article i mean has that
municipal government in victoria got
nothing better to do than to worry about
what is written
in a magazine
uh on on things that have nothing to do
with their municipality
besides which if you read the article
there is nothing particularly
offensive
nothing censorable in the article to
most objective observers
so
uh you know i in so far as canada is
concerned
i mean that that asians have a
reputation of being hard-working and
studious and not
party animals
uh there's probably some truth to that
that's not to say that all asians are
that way
yeah it's unfortunate that the term
asian is used indiscriminately to apply
both to people who just arrived here and
people who have been here for five
generations but
the vast majority of asians in our
people of asian origin in fact did
arrive the last 30 years in so far as
canada is concerned i think that's a
good thing personally uh i think that
canada
i don't believe in multiculturalism per
se i most of the people of asian origin
that i see young people they speak
english and and overwhelmingly their
culture is not that different from that
of of other canadians
and uh i think it's a good thing that
the people gradually get used to the
idea that
someone
who's canadian
can have a a funny name you know like
when i was a kid growing up my name is
kaufman
that wasn't quite as good as
smith jones or even la pierre because
originally canada was like english and
french so if you had a polish or german
or italian name that was kind of second
class that's no longer the case well by
the same token you may look uh indian
you may look chinese you may look
african you're just as canadian and i
think people are gradually getting used
to that but still
ah
there it remains true that people of in
certain groups
do tend to stick together which i think
is a little unfortunate
and uh and as a result that can cause
certain reactions amongst other people
in in in the community and so
newspapers and magazines should be
allowed to write about that
in this particular magazine
uh the mclean's magazine the article
didn't say
that we should reduce or limit or
restrict the number of asians at
university there's no such implication
at all if if anything it suggested that
uh that this was not the correct
approach and and i think it almost
implied that the whites were lazy or or
jealous or just didn't work hard enough
or whatever anyway there is nothing
there but the and uh i should add
that some of the loudest spokespeople
here like henry you i mean he strikes me
as a raving uh ethnic chauvinist
for for sort of
chinese canadianism i mean he published
he recently received i should add now
that i can go 15 minutes on itunes
on youtube
he managed to receive 900 000
from the federal government for a
chinese canadian history portal 900 000
and in accepting the money he said yes
you know we have to reassess how we look
at the history of canada because after
all he said a hundred years before
confederation there were two chinese
sailors on a ship that arrived on the
west coast of uh
canada
and so really uh the chinese were
interacting with the aboriginals here
at the same time as the europeans and so
the chinese are also a founding people
well that's just pure
uh nonsensical historical revisionism in
fact the europeans
were settled here
in the 1600s i mean john cabot was an
italian he was here in the 1500s he was
the captain of a ship we have basks
settling around the uh
the east coast basque fishermen we had
the massive arrivals of united empire
loyalists including germans and dutch
all before these two chinese sailors
showed up on a boat
but insofar as founding people every
country has its its myth of origin and
it's it's historical sort of founding
uh traditions and canada speaks english
and french and in the early years it was
this interaction between the the british
the french and the natives that formed
the core of what canada became through
its institutions and languages and so
forth that's not to say that we haven't
had all kinds of
italian chinese ukrainian german
japanese
jamaican
you name it indian others come here and
contribute of course they do but they
all end up speaking english and they all
conform to this
uh canadian
culture
that was originally uh established by
those founding people so
i
come from i was not born here i was born
in in sweden you know 60 years 62 years
ago
i came over here when i was five but my
family
conformed to the culture that was
already here so we are not a founding
people
uh similarly this vivian poi lady who is
a senator uh i mean i found a speech of
her she gave for the progressive muslims
society of canada
which is just full of the most amazing
stuff like she said tells the
progressive muslims that
uh you know she's a canadian senator
lived here for 50 years she says uh yeah
i'm
in my
uncle's company in hong kong we had a
muslim employee
and all i know is that muslims they're
just like us they look like chinese
except they don't eat pork well that's
not true because a lot of muslims in
china don't look chinese so she's kind
of wiped them out you know and then she
was on about how powerful the ming navy
was had ships that were larger than
columbus's ships and she fantasizes that
um you know if the ming navy had come
across the portuguese ships they would
have crushed them well no they didn't
they didn't the portuguese shift arrived
in ming china and founded macau and they
did their ships weren't crushed but yes
the chinese ships were larger so then
there's more of this kind of stuff
anyway
i think we're
i just
shudder at this sort of ethnic
chauvinism that's springing up and it's
its ability to
garner government funding
and to put pressure on
on uh
publications to try to force them to
apologize or to shut off their funding
scary stuff i hope it dies soon anyway
there's my
christmas boxing day rant before i head
off skiing thanks for listening bye for
now